you know those people who established
dynasties so powerful that endings echo
through the centuries I'm one of them
everything is just one big joke on the
island of Tropico your research team is
incompetent your diplomat is a snob and
your radio DJ is a bit promiscuous but
that's okay because both tropical five
and its digital inhabitants don't take
anything too seriously this realtime
strategy game raps it's a reverent wit
around some easily approachable
mechanics that smartly grow in
complexity as you move through the ages
and become more acquainted with your new
role as El Presidente okay hang on a
second I'm getting ahead of myself since
you don't actually start as El
Presidente in the beginning instead
tropical five starts you off as just a
lowly governor in the Victorian era
under the service of the crown from
these humble beginnings you must guide
your people through World War two in the
Cold War and beyond
each age brings with it a new set of
challenges at your tiny island nation is
sandwiched between the world's rotating
superpowers but as your trusted advisor
says it is your will alone that is
holding Tropico together and that means
doing anything and everything necessary
to stay in office whether it's rigging
the next election or putting down
civilian riots after all you're doing
this for the good of your people and
your Swiss bank account throughout the
ages your advisors take excellent care
and making sure ruling over your
citizens is as easy as it is enjoyable
even if you don't know a thing about
politics starting in the Victorian era
Lord Oaks worth emissary to the crown
guides you through building your first
resource gathering structures such as a
logging camp so that the king can
complete some harebrained scheme these
missions to build certain structures or
complete certain tasks continue
throughout the game and as you grow and
define the style of your nation they can
be accepted or ignored as needed however
each mission carries with it some sort
of political consequence usually it's a
trade-off between appeasing one faction
on the island and angering another such
as siding with the crown over the
revolutionaries or later the axis
supporters over the Allied supporters
thankfully you don't have to please
everyone
you just have to stay in power forever
virtually every choice you make from the
buildings you build to the people you
trade with will have some sort of impact
on your standing with the islands
various factions molding popular opinion
to your advantage is an enjoyable and
ever-changing challenge that grows in
complexity as you move through the ages
and more factions are introduced but
while this games simple mission design
is there to reel you in
it's Tropico 5 sense of humor that baits
the hook from the wording of your
islands Constitution to the musings of
your radio DJ this games a reverent
streak touches every aspect of the
island and in its own way this
devil-may-care attitude is fitting for
tropical five since the game isn't
concerned with breaking down every
little bit of minutiae for the player it
gives you just enough information to
make an informed decision without
leaving you lost in a maze of submenus
there's a lot to enjoy on the sandy
beaches of Tropico 5 whether you're
playing alone or with up to three others
online the game strikes a good balance
between style and substance that is easy
to digest for all types of strategy fans
and while the rest of the world tears
itself apart with world war this and
cold war that the simple minded Tropic
uns are always there to kick up their
feet and take it easy for all us sinners